- So what's something you've
done that you're like,
that might've been a little over the top?
Like...
(chuckling)
- Well I, you know, my
daughter recently got on,
she got an Instagram
account and like she had,
and I knew this would happen.
It took her a while to, you know,
I was like, okay just, and then, you know,
she's a quirky girl and she
has a quirky sense of humor.
And then this one girl,
who's also kind of quirky.
Oh, there she is.
She, she said something a little critical.
I'm sure every parents (laughing)
and I'm like, don't do it.
Like just let them work it out.
And I couldn't help it.
And I was like, you know,
I'm sure you have some
interesting habits too.
I don't think Charlotte's that weird.
And then I was like, 'cause my daughter
and I have different last
names, then I was like
this is Charlotte's mom, by the way.
And it's like, it's nice to meet you.
- Oh my god.
(laughing)
- Stop it.
So I can feel that impulse
and then just like step away.
But I don't know.
I mean, it's such a good question
because I don't want to imagine the worst.
And, but if something worst happened
I'm sure I would go to the worst place.
I don't know.
- Yeah.